I have done more matrix multiplying than you. That does not make you a machine learning. Why is this always a contest? Last time it was the blenders. This time I mentioned matrix multiply. Bryce's response, Connor, I'd just like you to know that I have done more matrix multiplication than you have in your lifetime. welcome to adsp the podcast episode 62 recorded on january 8th 2022 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we continue and finish part two of our 2021 retro. Yeah, well, we haven't, we've done my 2021 retrospective.
我做的矩阵乘法比你多。这并不意味着你就是机器学习。为什么这总是一场比赛？上次是搅拌机。这次我提到了矩阵乘法。布莱斯的回答是，康纳，我只想让你知道，我做过的矩阵乘法比你一生中做的还要多。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 62 期，于 2022 年 1 月 8 日录制，我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯将继续并完成我们 2021 年回顾的第二部分。是的，好吧，我们还没……我们已经做了我个人的 2021 年回顾。
What about your 2021 retrospective? Mine is, mine's mostly outside of work. So my work highlight, I worked on a really big project on the Rapids ecosystem called basically Decimal 128. I'm not going to go into the details, but it's like fixed point arithmetic.
你的 2021 年回顾呢？我个人的嘛，我的主要在工作之外。所以我的工作亮点是，我参与了 Rapids 生态系统中一个非常大的项目，基本上叫做 Decimal 128。我不打算深入细节，但它就像定点算术。
And it was a pretty big deal because there was compiler work that was done in order to support a bunch of work, a bunch of work that ended up that my team ended up having to do. Yeah. Yeah. Thanks. A 128 bit integers work. So thanks.
这算是一件挺大的事，因为为了支持大量的工作，其中有编译器方面的工作，而这些工作最终由我们团队来完成。是的。是的。谢谢。128 位整数的工作。所以谢谢。
Thanks to Wesley on my team for making that happen. Yeah. There was compiler folks. There was sort of on the standard library side, a bunch of stuff. So yeah, that was an awesome project. But my top three, starting number three, there was a trip I took in August that went to both Vancouver and then also to Winnipeg, I believe, to visit some friends and the family. That was the first time I'd been on a plane in over a year and a half. And more importantly, the first time I'd seen my family. So that was a big
感谢我们团队的韦斯利让这一切成为现实。是的。有编译器方面的人员。在标准库这边也有一堆东西。所以，是的，那是一个非常棒的项目。但我的前三名，从第三名开始，8 月份我有一次旅行，去了温哥华，然后我还去了温尼伯，我想是去拜访一些朋友和家人。那是我一年半多以来第一次坐飞机。更重要的是，那是我第一次见到我的家人。所以那是一件大事。
deal. Yeah, obviously, because of the pandemic, I basically didn't want to hop on a plane until I had my vaccines. Anyway, so that was awesome. Number two, what did I write down? Oh, yeah, both the podcasts and my book meetup. We finished category theory for programmers like this is like podcasting is like my substitute for conferences because you don't get i was just at like the the denver c++ meetup a couple days ago virtually he was not at person at the denver c++ meetup yeah virtually and um yeah man i just it's it's a very privileged statement but i just i miss i miss the conferences so much like you don't get to see like my my like socializing like my my most happy favorite socializing is like at those conferences well you know it's one of the things that i realized a few months into the
是的，很明显，因为疫情，在接种疫苗之前我基本上不想坐飞机。不管怎样，那太棒了。第二名，我记下了什么？哦，对了，播客和我的图书见面会。我们读完了《程序员的范畴论》，就像，做播客就像是我对会议的替代品，因为你无法获得——我几天前刚刚参加了丹佛 C++ 见面会，是以虚拟方式。他不是亲自去的，是在丹佛 C++ 见面会。是的，是以虚拟方式，然后，天哪，这话说出来可能有点特权阶层的感觉，但我真的太想念会议了。你知道，你没法像——我最开心、最喜欢的社交活动就是在那些会议上。好吧，你知道，在大流行几个月后我意识到的一件事是——
pandemic is and a couple months into the pandemic this was something that like I thought was a fear. It was something that was a fear of mine, but that I now recognize back at the at the you know 2011 to 2019 as this like golden age of tech conferences and this golden age of c++ conferences and that things never really went back to the way they were and i'm now fairly convinced that that's that that's the case so like you know like you and i it's sort of like peaked in 2019. You know, you and I both went. Where I went to the, that was my first conference. So I basically got the tail end of the golden age. Well, like you remember like November 2019, I went for like four weeks. I went to like, no, it was like six weeks.
在大流行开始几个月后，这曾被我视为一种恐惧。这是我曾经害怕的事情，但我现在认识到，回顾 2011 年到 2019 年的那段时期，那是科技会议的黄金时代，是 C++ 会议的黄金时代，而事情再也回不到过去了，我现在相当确信事实确实如此。所以就像你和我一样，它在 2019 年达到了顶峰。你知道，你和我两个人都去了。我去了那个，那是我的第一次会议。所以我基本上赶上了黄金时代的尾巴。就像你还记得 2019 年 11 月吗，我去了大约四个星期。我去了类似——不，是大约六个星期。
I went to a committee meeting and then Belfast. Yeah, it was the Belfast committee meeting. Then there was ACCU Belfast. And then there was also C++ Russia. And then there was meeting C++. And then I, and then like, like halfway through the trip, I had to like rebook to fly to supercomputing because one of my VPs was like, you need to go to supercomputing um and so i had just like five or six weeks of back-to-back conferences um and it was just in in like that that summer too i was in prague and then like paris and then uh we were in germany for the committee meeting um and like earlier in that year there was a ton of travel too and like there was it was just that, that fall I spent like eight weeks at conferences.
我先去参加了一个委员会会议，然后去了贝尔法斯特。是的，那是贝尔法斯特委员会会议。然后是 ACCU 贝尔法斯特。然后还有 C++ 俄罗斯。然后是 C++ Meetup。然后我——然后在行程过半时，我不得不重新预订机票去参加超级计算大会（Supercomputing），因为我的副总裁之一说，你需要去超级计算大会。所以我连续去了五六个星期的背靠背会议，而且就像——在那年夏天，我也去了布拉格，然后是巴黎，然后我们去德国参加委员会会议。那年早些时候也有大量的旅行，也就是那个秋天，我在会议上度过了大约八个星期。
Um, and then like COVID hit and then, uh, you know, it was all over. And I just like, I, I, I doubt that I'll, I'm sure I'll go to conferences again in the future. I, I sort of doubt that there will ever again be a situation where we'll have, you know, six or eight weeks of conferences back to back like that. Yeah, that's the thing is that I completely agree. There was a talk given at Strange Loop 2021 in October. I believe her name was Krista.
然后新冠疫情就爆发了，然后，你知道，这一切都结束了。我只是觉得，我——我——我怀疑我以后还会不会去参加会议。我有点怀疑未来是否还会出现那种我们连续参加六个星期或八个星期会议的情况。是的，关键是我完全同意。10 月份在 2021 年 Strange Loop 会议上有一个演讲。我想她的名字叫克里斯塔。
Actually, let me get her name because it's in a spreadsheet that's right here. Krista Lopes, Christina Lopes, although she goes by Krista Lopes. Wait, when you say spreadsheet, is it the spreadsheet? Yes. Portfolio of words on the videos tab. I watched that talk on December 30th, 2021. And yeah, she gave a talk. It was a keynote actually called the future of conferences. And it's a fantastic, it sounds like, oh, that's not going to be very exciting. It was one of my, it's a very good talk and talks about how there's trade-offs in that it increases the accessibility, reduces the, you know, carbon footprint if, you know, things are happening virtually, but there's also a ton of pros to, you know, having them in
其实，让我查一下她的名字，因为它就在这边的电子表格里。克里斯塔·洛佩斯（Krista Lopes），克里斯蒂娜·洛佩斯（Christina Lopes），虽然她通常被称为克里斯塔·洛佩斯。等等，你说的电子表格，是那个电子表格吗？是的。“视频”标签页上的作品集。我在 2021 年 12 月 30 日观看了那个演讲。是的，她做了一个演讲。实际上是一个主题演讲，叫做“会议的未来”。这是一个非常棒的——听起来可能觉得“哦，那不会太激动人心”。但那是我看过的非常好的演讲之一，它讨论了其中的权衡：如果事情以虚拟方式进行，它会增加可访问性，减少碳足迹，但将它们放在线下举行也有大量的好处。
person. And so I do think there still will be in-person conferences that are awesome, but yeah, it's, it's never going to go back to the way it was, I don't think. And that's the thing is I say it's like it's the best socializing or my favorite socializing. But like it's more than that. Like the intellectual growth or like the ideas that you come away with. And like that's the thing is this, you know, the Denver C++ meetup, it was great. We did this live code review. But then there were sort of two hours of casual chatting. Inevitably, it was like 80 minutes of that 120 minutes was just talking about people that know
所以我确实认为未来仍然会有非常棒的线下会议，但是，是的，它永远不会回到过去了，我认为不会。关键是，我说这是最好的社交活动，或者说是我最喜欢的社交活动。但它不仅于此。还有智力上的成长，或者说你从中获得的理念。这就是问题所在，你知道，丹佛 C++ 见面会，那很好。我们做了这个实时代码审查。但随后大约有两个小时的随兴闲聊。不可避免地，那 120 分钟里大概有 80 分钟都在谈论那些感染了病毒和新冠的人。这就有点——本质上并非技术性的。倒不是说对话必须是技术性的，但当你在 C++ 会议现场时，你谈论的 80% 的内容都只是在极客地讨论极客的事。你不会说“哦，我刚感染了病毒”或者“我要去打加强针了”。所以这既是社交，而且我每次去参加会议都能学到很多东西。此外，做完演讲后，总会有一群人在会后走过来，表现得很兴奋，想要交流——这种情景在虚拟会议上可没那么多。是的，我的意思是，线下和虚拟之间有一种氛围和化学反应。我觉得，当一切都变成纯粹的虚拟时，化学反应的丢失是一个现实，我不认为这是你能够真正完全弥补的。
people that got the virus and COVID. And it's like, it's not really technical in nature. Not that the conversation has to be technical, but like when're at C++ now, 80% of what you're talking about is just like you're nerding out on nerd stuff. You're not talking about, oh, I just got the virus or I'm going to get my booster vaccine. And so it's both socializing, but I learned so much every single time I was at some conference. And also, too, giving a talk, you always get a bunch of people afterwards that come up and are excited and want to talk about like, that doesn't happen as much at virtual conferences. Yeah, I mean, there's there's an atmosphere and a chemistry to, you know, in person versus, you know, virtual. I think like, like, I think it is a reality that there's like a loss of chemistry when things are, you know, solely virtual. And I don't think that that's something that you can ever really fully replace.
我们会看到的。让我们拭目以待，看看《头号玩家》1、2、3、4 代以及触觉套装会带来什么。并不是说我想穿着触觉套装去参加会议。尽管元宇宙对我们的股价很有利。Omniverse（全宇宙）。不是元宇宙。是 Omniverse。非常抱歉，黄仁勋。
We'll see. We'll see with, you know, Ready Player 1, 2, 3, 4, Haptic Suits. Not that I want a Haptic Suit to go to a conference. As good as the metaverse is for our stock price. Omniverse. Not the metaverse. Omniverse. I'm very sorry, Jensen.
非常抱歉，黄仁勋。我们是第一。我们是第一。我们是第一。我的意思是，元宇宙，那不是来自像《雪崩》或者别的什么吗？我不知道他们是从哪里抄来的。但无论如何，既然 Omniverse 对公司的股价一直这么好。你知道，我认为这是一项重要且基础的技术，将会带来变革，但正因为它是重要且具变革性的，它会被过度炒作。就像我对沃尔玛 VR 购物体验的看法一样。杂货配送的全部意义在于你不必亲自走进商店去挑选杂货。你支付溢价是为了获得比穿梭于实际店面寻找物品更好的购物体验。所以这显然是对该技术的错误使用。我确实认为 Omniverse 实际上非常酷。我在市里的一位英伟达同事就在从事 Omniverse 的工作，我和他聊过好几次，我总是对他的印象非常深刻。如果你去看看黄仁勋的一些 GTC 主题演讲，或者在 Facebook 发布其所谓的“元宇宙”公告之前关于 Omniverse 的一些演讲——所以，如果你去看看 2019 年、2020 年初的一些演讲，我认为它们确实很好地展示了一些能够真正带来变革的应用场景。我一直认为非常巧妙的事情之一是这个想法：如果你看看自动驾驶汽车的问题，为了获得足够的数据来充分训练自动驾驶汽车软件，使其达到道路安全标准，你需要比今天多几个数量级的实际道路行驶时间。因此，仅仅通过在路上开车去收集这些数据可能并不切实际。因此，Omniverse 的理念之一是：好吧，如果我们建立一个模拟环境，在其中模拟真实世界，然后在该模拟环境中训练神经网络，会怎么样？
Very sorry, Jensen. We were first. We were first. We were first. I mean, metaverse, isn't that from like the snow catcher, piercer? I don't know where they got it from. But anyways, as good as Omniverse has been for the company's stock price. You know, I think it's, it's one of those technologies that, that is important and foundational and will be transformative, but because it's important and
不仅仅是用于自动驾驶汽车。我认为其中一个主题演讲中实际展示的案例是将其用于机器人技术，例如在虚拟模拟现实中训练机器人。这简直——当我看到那个的时候，那才是我真正开窍的时刻。我看到它时就想：“哇，这真的很酷。”我看到了它的潜力。原因之一是，在我加入英伟达之前，我做过的事情之一是计算科学，这或多或少是同一个概念。你知道，我致力于对白矮星合并进行这些模拟。我们想要进行这些模拟的原因之一是，我们希望了解情况，获得比今天可能获得的更多的数据，因为有这些非常罕见的事件发生在非常非常遥远的地方。因此，我们对这些模拟所做的事情之一是，我们希望利用我们对其物理原理的理解来运行这些模拟，然后将模拟结果与实际观测结果进行比较，以确保模拟确实反映了现实。这已经成为当今大量科学的基础。
transformational, it will be overhyped. Like I the thing about the Walmart VR shopping experience. It's like the whole idea of grocery delivery is that you don't have to walk through the store to pick out the groceries. You're paying a premium to just have a better shopping experience than walking through an actual storefront and find things. And so that's just clearly a wrong use of the technology. I do think that Omniverse is actually very cool. One of my Nvidia colleagues who's in the city works on Omniverse, and I've chatted
你可能会在某些方面争辩说，许多高性能计算（HPC）在某种程度上某种形式上就是全宇宙（Omniverse）。现在，像 Omniverse 这样的大差别的在于它是可视化的。对于训练自动驾驶汽车或需要观察事物的机器人之类的事情，你需要一个实际的可视化的、实时的环境。是的，我会试着找几个展示机器人模拟训练的视频。因为，是的，有几个视频。有一个像高尔夫球的视频。有一个像迷你机器人和某种工厂环境的视频。而且，是的，看着它真的很开眼界，会觉得“哦，对，原来还有这种事”。
about it a couple times, and I'm always very impressed with him. If you go and look at some of Jensen's GTC keynotes or some of the talks about Omniverse before, you know, Facebook made its, like, metaverse announcement, so, like, if you go look at, look at some of the talks from 2019, early 2020, I think that really does a good job of showcasing some of the use cases that can be really transformative. One of the things that I always thought was very clever was this idea that if you look at the self-driving car problem, to get the amount of data that you would need to really like train self-driving car software sufficiently to be, you know, road safe, you would need need orders of magnitude more hours on the actual road than you have today. And so it may just not be practical to go and gather that data, just like driving around on the road. And so one of the ideas of the Omniverse was, okay, well, what if we built a simulation environment where we could, you know, simulate the real world and then train the neural nets in that simulated environment?
是的，你知道，像机器学习和 Omniverse、数据科学这些事情挺搞笑的，你知道，我觉得通常那些在这些领域工作或与这些领域相邻的人，因为周围有太多的炒作，我们有时会有一种悲观的展望。就好像，哦，你知道的，每个人都对机器学习感到兴奋。每个人都认为机器学习将解决他们所有的问题。现在每家公司都有一个数据科学和机器学习部门。而且，你知道，这是一场淘金热，并且，你知道，所有人都被过度炒作了，但每隔一段时间，你就会被提醒这样一个事实：这些东西被过度炒作的原因是因为它们确实是令人惊叹的变革性技术，它们对世界产生了巨大的影响。
And not just for self-driving cars. I think the actual use case that was shown in one of the keynotes was doing this for robotics of like, you know, training the robots in this virtual simulated reality. And that's just like, when I saw that, that's really when it clicked for me. And I just like, you know, I saw that and I was like, wow, this is really cool. And I think it's potential. And one of the reasons is that, you know, before I worked at NVIDIA, one of the things I did was computational science, which is more or less the same idea. You know, I worked on doing these simulations of white dwarf mergers. And one of the reasons why we want to do those simulations is we want to understand, we want to get more data than we can possibly get today because there are these very rare events
是的。是的。你这么说，让我想起了一个事实：从技术上讲，RAPID 属于人工智能基础设施。从技术上讲，我可以到处说，是的，我从事人工智能基础设施工作，这并不算假，但我从来不说。当人们问我做什么时，我只是，你知道，说我从事一个加速 Python 库的 C++ 后端工作。因为我觉得说我从事 AI 基础设施工作，实在有点——我知道 Facebook 有一个相当的团队，他们穿着写着 AI infra 的夹克。
that happen very, very far away. And so one of the things that we do with these simulations is we want to run these simulations with our understanding of how the physics of them work and then compare the simulated results to actual observational results to make sure that the simulation actually reflects reality. And that's become the basis of a ton of science today.
就像，你知道，巴塔哥尼亚夹克。而我只是——我就是做不到，因为我——我知道人们对 AI 的语义依恋，就像，你知道，好莱坞电影之类的。而我觉得——我做的事情没那么性感。它很棒。真的很酷。但它不是——不是人们想象的那样。嗯，我认为原因之一是，在某种程度上，AI（或者我更喜欢说机器学习，因为我认为 AI 带有更多公众面向的术语——AI 是一个非常广泛的领域，我们今天所做的大部分 AI 其实都是机器学习。所以，你知道，我喜欢，你知道，经常对人们说，比如，你知道，我对机器学习一无所知，这并非完全不真实。而且，比如，我肯定不会说我从事的是机器学习和人工智能的核心基础设施工作，尽管这某种程度上也算真的。但我认为，也许会有一些犹豫的原因之一是，机器学习淘金热确实……）
I think that you could argue in some ways that a lot of HPC is in some ways some form of the omniverse. Now, the big difference with something like omniverse is that it's visual. For something like training self-driving cars or a robot that needs to see things, you need an actual visual, real-time environment. Yeah, I'll try and find a couple of the videos that show the robot simulation training. Because, yeah, there's a couple ones. There's one, like a golf one. There's like a mini robot and sort of a factory thing. And, yeah, it's very mind-op opening watching it and being like oh yeah that's
我在想怎么把话说得好听点，机器学习淘金热已经以某种方式改变了优先级，使得计算科学和软件工程的某些特定领域觉得自己在舞会上被抛弃去约会别人了。你知道，传统的高性能计算（HPC），传统的计算在过去几年里已经退居二线，以满足机器学习和深度学习（ML/DL）的需求。当然，从 HPC 的角度来看，许多完成的硬件创新都围绕着加速机器学习。现在，许多这样的硬件加速可以被 HPC 利用，许多传统的 HPC 开始使用机器学习技术。但我认为，出现某种反应是有点自然的，比如，哦，那是无稽之谈。这只是将优先级从真正的科学或我们正在做的事情上转移开。但我得说，我总是很自豪地说我致力于赋能数据科学框架。因为，不知道为什么，数据科学在我看来更显高尚。
a thing yeah you know it's it's funny with things like machine learning and omniverse um in data science um you know like i think i feel like oftentimes some of us who are working in or adjacent to those fields, because there's so much hype around it, we sometimes have like a pessimistic outlook. It's like, oh, it's like, you know, everybody's excited about machine learning. Everybody thinks that machine learning is going to solve all their problems. Every company's got, you know, a data science and a machine learning division now. And, you know, it's a gold rush and, and, you know, everybody's overhyped, but like every now and then you, you get reminded of the fact that like the reason that these things are overhyped is because they are actually amazing transformational technologies, which are having a huge impact on the world.
是的，我的意思是，回想起来感觉挺诡异的。《时代》杂志年度风云人物不是黄仁勋吗，或者诸如此类？年度人物？整个个人资料都在说英伟达是引领人工智能、无论什么前沿的公司，诸如此类。所以对我来说，我很高兴说我和构建数据科学框架的人一起工作，并且有一种“数据科学更崇高”的直觉的原因之一是，我认为很多人涉足了机器学习，许多人和组织涉足了机器学习，并把它当作了一把锤子。就像，“哦，是的，我们只要把一些机器学习塞进我们的东西里，就会很棒。”而现实是，并非每个人都必然拥有足够的数据来做到这一点。如果它能塞进一个电子表格里，你猜怎么着？那这就不是大数据。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, you say that, and it makes me think about the fact that technically RAPID sits under the AI infrastructure. And technically, I could go around saying that, yeah, I work on artificial intelligence infrastructure, which is like it's not false, but I never say that. Like when people ask me what I do, I just, you know, say, I work on the C++ backend for a accelerated Python library. Because I just feel like such a, like saying that I work on AI infrastructure. Like I know that there's an equivalent team at Facebook and they have jackets that say AI infra on them.
但是，嗯，你知道，数据科学其实就是这样一个领域——数据科学就像是利用技术、算法和系统从数据（可能是充满噪声的数据）中获取见解的领域。所以，它不一定非要使用机器学习。它只是说：我们有数据，那么，我们如何从这些数据中提取知识？对我来说，这就像是一把锤子，我认为几乎任何人都可以拿起它并从中获得有用的东西。如果你有数据——几乎任何数量的数据——是的，你大概都可以利用数据科学从这些数据中学习到一些东西。好吧。我们刚才聊了漫长的一大串，从播客和我的见面会（排名第二）到我
Like, you know, Patagonia jackets. And I just like, I just can't do it because I just like, I know that the semantic attachment that people have to AI, it's like, you know, the Hollywood movies and stuff. And I'm just like, it's not that sexy what I do. Like, it's awesome. It's really cool. But it's not, it's not what people think. Well, I think one of the reasons is that to some degree, the AI, or I really prefer to say machine learning, because I think AI is much more
想念会议，到 Omniverse，再到我们在英伟达工作并且我们懂人工智能——除了我们其实不懂，但——是的，我们确实在某种程度上懂数据科学，我们认识懂这些东西的人。是的，我们确实认识懂这些东西的人。是的，大多数时候我只是使用 Thrust 并行算法，而且，是的，我们也不懂图形学——就像引擎团队里的那群人一样——除了少数几个例外，大多数英伟达的 C++ 程序员其实并不懂图形学，也不大懂机器学习，这挺搞笑的，因为如果你去了解的话——这恰恰是英伟达比较出名的两个领域。我的意思是，我确实——我不懂机器学习，但我确实做过很多
of a public-facing term. Like, AI is a very broad field, and the majority of the AI that we're doing today is machine learning. So, you know, I like, you know, often say to people, like, you know, I know nothing about ML, which is not entirely untrue. And, like, I certainly wouldn't, like, say that, like, I work on, like, you know, core infrastructure for ML and AI, although that is kind of, like, true. But I think one of the reasons that there's perhaps some hesitance there is that it is true that the ML gold rush has,
矩阵乘法，当我还在学习成为精算师的时候。所以我听说那是其中大约 80% 的工作。所以我做过的矩阵乘法比你多。这并不能让你成为一个机器学习者。上次是搅拌机。这次我提到了矩阵乘法，布莱斯的回答是：“康纳，我只想让你知道，我做过的矩阵乘法比你一辈子做的还要多。”我编写过优化的矩阵乘法算法。我觉得，那你为什么还说自己不懂机器学习？这就好听说——我听说那基本上就是全部内容了。
um, I'm thinking about how to say this nicely, has the ML Gold Rush has shifted priorities in ways that have left certain, certain domains of computational science and software engineering feeling like they've sort of been abandoned at the prom for another date. You know, like traditional HPC, traditional compute has sort of taken a backseat to the needs of ML and DL over the past few years. And certainly from like the HPC perspective, you know, a lot of the hardware innovation that gets done has been around accelerating ML. Now, a lot of that hardware acceleration can be leveraged by HPC
就像，那是线性代数。那是另一个领域。机器学习就像是一个应用这些技术的特定领域。我想我可能在我的本科阶段，我在路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）的数学教育中，那个系非常非常专注于理论，或者至少我所在的课程非常专注于理论。它被称为应用数学，但它非常专注于图论。它其实并不是一个计算性很强的专业，这也是我喜欢它的原因。我想我以前在播客里说过这个。我没有获得计算机科学学位，因为当时我知道自己是个小混蛋，有点自大。我当时想，如果我读计算机科学专业，我会觉得自己比教授聪明，然后我会和他们起冲突。接着我会过得很痛苦。而且我也讨厌学校。所以我想，如果我热爱的事情——也就是编程、计算机科学和软件 engineering——如果这就是我必须在学校里学习的东西，我会过得很痛苦，这会让我开始讨厌这些东西。这就是为什么我最终获得了一个数学学位。而且我有意选择了路易斯安那州立大学里最不——
and a lot of traditional HPC is starting to use machine learning techniques. But I think it's a little bit natural for there to be some reaction of like, oh, that's like, oh, that's nonsense. And it's just shifting priorities away from like the real, you know, the real science or the real thing that we're doing. But I will say I am always proud to say that I work on enabling data science frameworks. Because, I don't know, something about data science feels more noble to me.
它不是计算量最少的，但它是倒数第二少计算量的，也就是应用数学专业。那是那种不需要修任何计算机科学课程的专业——我是故意选那个的。而且——我不知道我们当时是否上过任何机器学习或神经网络课程，因为那是 2011 到 2014 年左右，当时它不像现在这么突出。我肯定学过很多适用的图论，这些理论适用于
Yeah, I mean, it is weird to think. Didn't Jensen, wasn't he man of the year, time of the year person or whatever? Person of the year? And the whole profile was NVIDIA is the company leading the AI, whatever, frontier, something like that. So to me, one of the reasons why I'm happy to say that I work with people that build data science frameworks and have this gut reaction that data science is more noble is that I think a lot of people pick up ML and a lot of people and a lot of organizations have picked up ML and have like, sort of treated it as like a hammer. Um, like, oh yeah, we'll just like, we'll just throw some machine learning into like our thing and it'll be great. Um, and the reality is that like, not everybody necessarily has the amount of data, um, to, to, to like, you know, to do that. If it fits in a spreadsheet, guess what? It's not big data.
当今使用的机器学习技术，尽管大部分知识已经从我的脑海中流失了。仍然有一些图论证明，我为了某些考试不得不学习，我相当确信，如果在压力下并且需要产生这些证明，我大概能硬生生推导出一个三页纸的荒谬证明。听起来是个挑战。是的。我还——我——你知道，这很有趣。
But, um, but you know, data science is really just this field like data science is just like the field of using like techniques and algorithms and systems to get insights out of data, you know, potentially noisy data. So like, it's not necessarily, you know, using machine learning. It's just like, we have data, like, you know, how do we extract knowledge out of that data? And that to me, like, that's the sort of hammer that I think is one that almost anybody can pick up and get something useful out of. Like if you have data, you know, almost any quantity of data, yeah, you can probably use data science to learn something from that data. Yeah. All right. Well, we just went on a huge, we went from podcasts and my meetup is number two to I
因为我曾经是一个从事高性能计算（HPC）的人，但我勉强在偏微分方程课程中活了下来。就像，微分方程和微积分从来都不是我的天赋所在。像图论，你知道，图论和离散数学，这些对我来说都很自然，但是微积分——不，不，不，不，不，不。是的，我的意思是微积分一和二还好，但一触及多元微积分和三维微积分，我——是的，我讨厌应用题。我曾经很喜欢应用题，但我只记得会有某种圆锥体和水，水以某种速率流出，水又被倒进圆锥体里。我的问题在于，一旦你进入偏微分方程之类的领域，为了解这些问题，你必须对如何去做有一种直觉——我的教授 literalmente 字面意思是这么对我说过的，你必须对如何去做有一种直觉。
miss conferences to Omniverse to we work at nvidia and we know ai except we don't but yeah we do we do kind of know data science we know people that know stuff yeah we know we do know people that know stuff yeah mostly i just use thrust parallel algorithms and yeah we also don't know graphics like like the group of like engine like all the nvidia c++ people with a couple exceptions most of the nvidia c++ people don't know graphics and don't really know machine learning which is funny because like if you meet it like those are the two things that nvidia is kind of known for i do i mean i don't i don't know machine learning but I did do a lot
字面意思是，我的教授就是这么对我说过的，你必须对如何切入这个问题有正确的直觉。而且，不知道为什么，我就是缺乏那种直觉。是的。我从来没上过偏微分方程（PDE）或常微分方程（ODE）。我仍然有——就在这个书架上，这些甚至都不是我的课程偏微分方程书。这些是我为了学会如何做我的工作而不得不买的研究生级别的 PDE 书籍。为了学习我做计算天体物理学和其他研究所需的数学。
of matrix multiplication when I was studying to be an actuary. So I hear that's like 80% of it. So I have done more matrix multiplying than you. It does not make you a machine learner. Last time it was the blenders. This time I mentioned matrix multiply Bryce's response, Connor, I just liked you to know that I have done more matrix multiplication than you have in your lifetime. I have written optimized matrix multiplication algorithms. I feel like why are you saying you don't know machine learning then? That's like I've heard that's like basically all it is.
好了，别再用我们的数学——甚至都算不上成功——来折磨我们的听众了，或者说折磨听众了，抱歉。听起来我们俩在最后都挣扎得很痛苦。我的意思是，我认为让人知道这一点是件好事。比如，你知道，我觉得我擅长数学。实际上我认为我很强，我的口头和沟通能力更强。我记得当我参加 SAT 考试时——这是美国大学入学考试。
Like that's that's linear algebra. That's a different field. Like machine learning is like a specific field of like, of like applying these techniques. I think I probably took in, in my undergrad, my, my, my math education at LSU, the department was very, very theory focused, or at least the program I was in was very theory focused. It was called applied math, but it was very focused on like graph theory. It was not, not really a very computational program, which is actually why I liked it. I think I've said this on the podcast before. I did not get a computer science degree because at the time I knew I was a little shit and like a little arrogant shit. And I thought that if I was going to be in a computer science
数学部分对我来说总是很难，这很奇怪，因为我以前是个理科小孩，你知道的，就像——我父母确信我会获得一个 STEM（科学、技术、工程、数学）学位之类的。这始终是我感兴趣的领域。但是，数学，仅仅因为我喜欢科学并不意味着我擅长数学，而在科学领域走得远你需要擅长数学。我数学部分很挣扎，最后考得还不错，但 SAT 的语言部分我根本不用复习，考了满分。哇，我们简直是截然相反。是的，是的，但——人们对我的期望并不是这样的，当他们见到我时，他们会说：“哦，你是个软件工程师，你拥有数学学位，写作肯定不是你的强项。”
degree, I would think that I was smarter than my professors and I would clash with them. And then I would be miserable. And also I hated school. And so I figured like if the thing that I loved, which is programming and computer science and software engineering, if that was like what I had to like study in school, that I was just going to be miserable and it would make me hate those things. So that's why I ended up getting a math degree. And I like intentionally picked the math course and the math degree program at lsu that was like the least
但现实是，写作和沟通对我来说是天生自然的，而数学是我不得不与之搏斗的东西。在某种程度上，这也是我选择获得数学学位的原因之一。部分原因正是出于这种考虑——我不想获得计算机科学学位，因为我觉得我会和教授争论。而且因为我从未享受过学校生活，我喜欢编程，我不想通过在学校里学习编程来开始讨厌编程。但另一个原因是——我想过，我现在会编程。我觉得我不需要去学校学习这个。但我不知道的是数学。所以我要去获得一个数学学位，希望能借此更多地了解它。所以我想这也许不是很多人会做的事情。很多人认为我要去我擅长的领域上大学。我有意识地选择了一个我不擅长的领域的学位，以便能学到更多。这其实——天哪，我们在这些事情上有很多来回，
um it wasn't the least computational but it was like the second least computational which was the applied math program um uh it was like the one where you did not have to take any cs courses um like i intentionally picked that one um uh and uh i I don't know that we ever took any machine learning or neural net courses at the time because that was like 2011, 2014 and you know it wasn't as prominent as it is now there was definitely a lot of like applicable graph theory that I learned that was you know applicable to
除了装修公寓之外，我们在其他方面是多么相似，那正是我们真正存在分歧的地方。但实际上，我们在播客上讨论过很多次大学或者说我们过去的经历，这真的很疯狂，我基本上做了完全相同的决定。所以，我一直对数学有一种某种倾向。但在第三学期的某个时刻，我修了两门计算机科学课程，也就是两门入门课程。因为它们有带加分的项目之类的东西，我在两门课上都拿到了百分之百以上的分数。我爱死它了。而且我当时已经在朝着精算数学努力了。所以我面临一个选择。当时我认为——我现在认为那是个错误，我当时对计算机科学一无所知，对软件工程和谷歌之类的东西一无所知，也不知道这是一个蓬勃发展的行业。我的看法只是，“哦，计算机科学这东西超级有趣，我喜欢用 Python 编写代码”，但我决定继续学习精算数学，因为我觉得我会对计算机科学感到厌倦。计算机科学太有趣了，我喜欢用 Python 编写代码，但我决定继续坚持精算数学，因为我觉得我可能会对计算机科学感到厌倦，因为它太简单了。至少，我的意思是，那是种天真无知的看法，因为我当时并不知道它在 200、300、400 级时会变得更难。我只是觉得自己会一直考得很好。而我知道精算数学——尽管我擅长数学——是一个竞争极其激烈且困难的领域，比如你为了进入这个项目必须参加的精算入门课程。我想我得了 B 减或 C 加，而且那是一门非常、非常——
machine learning techniques that are used today although most of that knowledge has drained out of my head there are still like a handful of like graph proofs that I had to like learn for like some test that I'm fairly certain that if under pressure and like presented with like the need to produce these proofs, I could probably like crank out like one of these like three page ridiculous proofs. Sounds like a challenge. Yeah. I also got, I, I, I, you know, it's funny.
其实，不对，我的成绩比 C 加高，因为你需要达到某个最低分数。但为了那门课，我付出的努力比大学里之前任何一门课都要多，结果却考得非常非常差。那门课的淘汰率高达 50%。所以重点是，当时我想，哦，我要选这个。它会更有挑战性。事后回想起来，我认为这是一个错误。但这很有趣，我们俩都做出了同样的决定，去尝试更有挑战性的东西。其实——我要争辩说，我不认为那是个错误，康纳。而且，我的意思是，你知道，
Cause I was, I was somebody that was in, you know, HC, but I barely survived my, like, partial differential equations coursework. Like, that, like, differential equations and calculus never came naturally to me. Like, graph theory, you know, like, graph theory and, like, discrete math math um like that was all like very natural to me but like the calculus nope nope nope nope nope nope yeah i mean calculus calculus one and two um was fine but as soon as it hit multivariate and three i just yeah i hated the word problems um and i used to love word problems but I just remember there would be like some cone and water and water leaving at a certain rate and water being poured into the cone
我想这可能并不适用于每个领域。可能还有其他领域（甚至在科技领域之外，也许在科技领域内部），你确实需要拥有特定领域的学位才能在该领域找到工作。但在科技领域——在科技领域，你不需要拥有特定的学位类型就能成为一名软件工程师。土木工程并非如此。如果你想成为一名土木工程师，你需要去获得一个土木工程学位。如果你想成为一名会计师或律师，你也需要去法学院，需要获得一个会计学位。但是，我认为如果你正计划进入一个领域，或者即使你不知道自己将进入哪个领域，寻找那些不那么自然地属于你、会挑战你但你认为在职业生涯中会需要的课程、教育和学位项目，依然是有价值的。
and there was my problem was that like once you get to like partial differential equations like you to like solve these problems like you just had to have an intuition about like how to do it like literally my professors would tell me, like you just had to have an intuition about like how to do it.
所以，你知道，我认为它对你的帮助可能比你想象的要大，因为我认为你所拥有的那些精算技能为你打下了数学和统计学的背景，并在某种程度上为你打下了数据科学的背景，这让你作为一名软件工程师显得非常独特，并为你提供了独特的视角。所以，如果你转了专业，你可能就不会有如此多元化的技能组合了。我想你在某种程度上确实是对的，我也同意我的——我 považujem 视自己为统计学家，因为我修了太多的统计学课程，而且精算数学要求你背诵所有这些分布，伯努利、二项式、韦伯等等，或者你不一定非要背下来，但你需要知道如何使用它们。
Like literally my professors would tell me that, like you just have to have the right intuition about like how to approach this. And like, I don't know, I just lacked that intuition. Yeah. I never took PDE or ODE. I still have like, I have right here on this shelf, like my, these actually aren't even my coursework PDE books. These were like the graduate level PDE books that I had to pick up to like learn how to do my job. Like to learn the math that I needed to do the computational astrophysics and other stuff that I was doing.
因此我学到了大量知识，但唯一的遗憾是，沿着这条路走下去，我花了——这不是夸张——数千小时的时间来准备精算考试，因为一共有八门。有些你有时会挂科。我想我挂了三门、四门，也许五门。
All right. Well, enough with boring our listeners with, or boring the listener, sorry, with our mathematics, not even successes. It sounds like we both struggle towards the end. I mean, I think it's a good thing for people to know. Like, you know, like I, I think, I think I'm good at math. I actually think that I'm strong, my, my like, my verbal and my like communication skills are stronger. Like I remember when I took the SATs, which are like the, the college like entrance exams in the US.
每一次你都得复习四五百个小时。我在这些考试上浪费了大量时间。而且它们是设计得很糟糕的考试。它们的重点不是考察你理解了多少，而是给你 2000 页的材料，然后只考其中的 10%靠运气。所以有一半时间全凭运气。我觉得有那么好几年，我一直在为一个目标努力，而一旦完成，我就立刻转行了。不过我得说，从这段经历中，可以说我获得的最宝贵的财富之一就是一种疯狂的工作伦理——或者我不该用“疯狂”这个词。就是一种非常、非常——我的、我的、我的……
I got like, like the math section was like always like hard for me, which was weird because like, I was like a science kid, you know, like, like, like my parents were like convinced I was going to like get, get a STEM degree and whatnot. Like that was always what interested me. Um, but like the math, like, um, just because I liked science doesn't mean it didn't mean I was good at math, which you need to be to like go far in science. But like the math section I struggled with i ended up doing pretty good but the like verbal section of the like sats like i didn't have to study for and i got like a perfect score um wow we're like opposites uh yeah yeah yeah but like like people don't expect that from like me um when they meet me they're like oh like you're a software engineer you have a math
我觉觉得数学部分对我来说总是很难，这挺奇怪的，因为我以前是个理科生，你知道的，我父母坚信我会去拿一个STEM学位之类的。那一直是我感兴趣的方向。嗯，但是数学，呃，仅仅因为我喜欢科学并不意味着我擅长数学，而你在科学上要走得远就需要数学。但数学部分我学得很挣扎，最后其实考得还不错，而像SAT的语言部分，我根本不用复习，就考了满分，呃，哇，我们就像是相反的。呃，对，对，但人们不会对我抱有这种期望，当他们见我时，他们会觉得，哦，你是个软件工程师，你有一个数学
degree like you know writing can't be your strong suit, but, like, the reality is, like, writing and communicating, like, that is, like, just natural to me, whereas math is something that I had to struggle with, and to some degree, that's why I chose to get a math degree, you know, as part of it was that sort of, like, reason, like, I didn of like reason, like, I didn't want to like, I didn't want to, um, get a CS degree because I thought I would argue with my professors. And cause I, I'd never enjoyed school and I enjoyed programming and I didn't want to like combine, I didn't want to come to hate programming through studying it in the school. But like the other reason was like, I thought about like, you know, I know how to program
学位，所以你知道，写作不可能是你的强项，但现实是，写作和沟通对我很自然，而数学是我不得不挣扎面对的。某种程度上，这也是我选择攻读数学学位的原因，你知道的，部分原因就是那种，嗯，我不想，我不想去拿一个计算机科学学位，因为我觉得我会和教授吵架。而且因为我从来不觉得学校有意思，我喜欢编程，我不想把编程和它结合起来，我不想因为在学校里学编程而开始讨厌编程。但另一个原因是，我当时想，你知道的，我懂得怎么编程
right now. I don't think I need to go to school to learn that. But the thing that I don't know is math. And so I'm going to go to get a degree in math to hopefully, you know, learn more about it. So I guess that's maybe not something that a lot of people think to do. Like a lot of people think like I'm going to go to college in the field that I'm good at. I consciously chose to get a degree in the field that I'm bad at so that I could learn more about it. This is actually, man, it's, we, we have these back and forths on, uh,
现在。我不觉得我需要去学校学那个。但我不知道的是数学。所以我要去拿一个数学学位，希望能借此了解更多。所以我想这可能不是很多人会做的事。很多人觉得我要去上大学，学我擅长的领域。而我是刻意选择了一个我并不擅长的领域去拿学位，这样我才能学到更多。说实话，老兄，我们经常有这样的来回讨论，关于
how similar we are except for furnishing our apartments, which is where we really differ. But it's actually, that's crazy that we've talked about university quite a bit on this podcast or like our past experiences, but I basically had the exact same decision. Like, so I, I always had a, whatever predisposition towards math. But at one point in my third semester, I had taken two computer science courses, the two intro ones. And because they had projects with bonus marks and stuff, I got a hundred percent above a hundred percent, um, in both of those classes. And I loved it. And I, I was already working towards the actuarial math. And so I had a choice. And at the time I, and I consider this a mistake at the time, I didn't know that like computer science, I didn't know anything about software engineering and Google
我们有多相似，除了装修公寓这方面我们真的很有分歧。但实际上，我们在播客里讨论过好多次大学或者说过去的经历，这真的很疯狂，我当时面对的决定几乎一模一样。比如，我一直对数学有一种天然的倾向。但有一次，在我的第三个学期，我上了两门计算机科学课，就是那两门入门课。因为有带加分项的项目之类的，我在那两门课里都考了百分之百以上的分数，嗯。而且我太喜欢了。我当时已经在朝精算数学的方向努力了。所以我面临一个选择。当时我认为这是一个错误，我当时并不知道计算机科学，我根本不懂软件工程师和谷歌
and stuff. And that it was like a, you know, growing industry. My view was just that like, Oh, computer science is this super fun thing. I love coding in Python, but I decided to continue with the actuarial math thing. Cause I figured I was going to get bored with computer science is this super fun thing. I love coding in Python, but I decided to continue with the actuarial math thing because I figured I was going to get bored with computer science because it was just so easy. At least, I mean, that was a naive, ignorant view because I didn't know, you know, that it's going to get harder at the 200, 300, 400 level. I just figured I was going to continue to be able to do well. Whereas I knew actuarial math, even though I'm good at math, it was an extremely competitive and difficult, like the introductory actuarial course that you have to take in order to get into the program. I think I got like a B minus or a C plus and it was a very, very,
之类的是什么，也不知道那是一个蓬勃发展的行业。我的看法只是，哦，计算机科学这东西太好玩了，我喜欢用Python写代码，但我决定继续学精算数学，因为我觉得我可能会对计算机科学感到厌倦，因为计算机科学这东西太好玩了，我喜欢用Python写代码，但我决定继续学精算数学，因为我觉得我可能会对计算机科学感到厌倦，因为它太简单了。至少，我是说，那是一种幼稚、无知的看法，因为我不知道它在200、300、400年级会变得更难。我当时只觉得自己能一直学得很好。而我知道精算数学，尽管我擅长数学，但那是一个极具竞争力和难度的专业，比如你为了进这个专业必须上的精算入门课。我想我得了一个B减或者C加，那是一门非常、非常
actually, no, I got higher than a C plus because you needed a certain minimum grade. But like I had studied harder for that course than any other course up to that point in university and done very, very poorly. And the course had like a 50% dropout rate. So the point being is I was like, oh, I'll do this. It'll be more challenging. In hindsight, I think it was a mistake. But it's just interesting that we both made the same decision to try something that was more challenging. I actually – I'm going to argue that I don't think that it was a mistake, Connor. And, and I mean, you know,
其实，不对，我考得比C加高，因为你需要达到某个最低成绩。但为了那门课，我付出的努力比大学里之前任何一门课都要多，结果却考得非常非常差。而且那门课的挂科率高达50%。所以重点是，当时我想，哦，我要选这个。这会更有挑战性。事后看来，我觉得这是一个错误。但有趣的是，我们俩都做了同样的决定，去尝试更有挑战性的东西。其实——我要说的是，我不认为那是个错误，康纳。而且，我的意思是，你知道的，
I think this is probably not applicable to every field. There's probably other fields outside of tech, you know, maybe even in tech where you really do need to have, you know, a degree in a particular field to get a job in that field. But, you know, in tech, like, in tech, you don't need to have a particular degree type to become a software engineer. That's not true for civil engineering. If you want to become a civil engineer, you need to go get a civil engineering degree. Ditto for other, if you want to be an accountant or a lawyer, you need to go to law school, you need to get an accounting degree. But like, I think that if you're planning on going into a field, or even if like, you don't know what field you're going is something to be said for seeking out the courses and the education and the degree program that does not come naturally to you and that challenges you, but that is like something that
我觉得这可能并不适用于所有领域。可能在科技行业之外还有其他领域，甚至在科技行业内部，你也确实需要拥有某个特定领域的学位才能找到相关的工作。但是，你知道，在科技行业，在科技行业你不需要特定的学位就能成为一名软件工程师。土木工程就不是这样。如果你想成为一名土木工程师，你需要去取得一个土木工程学位。会计师或律师也是如此，你需要去法学院，你需要取得一个会计学位。但是，我觉得如果你正打算进入一个领域，或者即使你不知道自己要进入什么领域，去寻找那些对你来说并非轻而易举、能给你带来挑战，但又是你认为
you think that you'll need in your career. So like, you know, like I think that it probably has helped you more than you think about it, because I think that those like actuarial skills that you have, they give you this, this background in like math and statistics and, and to some degree, like data science that sort of like make you like unique as a software engineer and give you like a unique perspective on things. So like, I think, I think that you, I think that you would not have as diverse a skillset if you had switched programs. switch programs i think you're definitely correct to an extent and i agree that like my like i consider myself a statistician because i took so many stats courses and you know actual math you have to memorize all these distributions bernoulli binomial whatever weibel etc or you don't have to
在职业生涯中会用到的课程、教育和学位项目，这依然是非常有价值的。所以，你知道的，我觉得它对你的帮助可能比你想象的要大，因为我觉得你拥有的那些精算技能，为你打下了数学和统计学的背景，并在某种程度上类似于数据科学，这让你作为一名软件工程师显得非常独特，并为你提供了一个独特的视角。所以，我觉得，我觉得如果你当初转了专业，你的技能就不会这么多元了。转了专业。我想你在某种程度上绝对是正确的，我也赞同我的，我把自己视为统计学家，因为我上了那么多统计课，而且你知道精算数学，你必须记住所有这些分布，伯努利、二项分布、韦布尔分布等等，或者说你不一定非得
memorize them but you need to know how to use them. And so I learned a ton, but the one regret is that taking that path, I spent, and this is not an exaggeration, thousands of hours studying for actuarial exams because there's eight of them. You fail some of them sometimes. I failed, I think, three, four, maybe five.
记住它们，但你需要知道如何使用它们。所以我学到了非常多的东西，但我唯一的遗憾是，走了那条路之后，我花了——这不是夸张——几千个小时来备考精算考试，因为总共有八门考试。有时候你有些科目会挂掉。我想我挂了三门、四门，可能五门。
And each time you have to study, you know, four or 500 hours. I spent so much time spinning my wheels on these exams. And they're terribly designed exams. They're not focused on like, you know, how much you comprehend, they give you 2000 pages of material, and then they only test 10% of it. So it's just like, it's luck of the draw half the time. And I just think that there was like, there was a number of years that I was working towards something that like, as soon as I finished it, I switched. Although I will say, out of that, arguably, one of the most valuable things that I got was like an insane work ethic or I shouldn't use the word insane. Just like a very, very, my, my, my,
而且每次你都得复习四五百个小时。我在这些考试上白白浪费了太多时间。而且这些考试设计得太糟糕了。它们关注的不是你理解了多少，而是给你两千页的材料，然后只考其中的10%。所以这有一半的时候完全是靠运气。我觉得有那么好几年，我都在为一件事情努力，结果刚一考完我就转行了。不过我得说，从中获得的、可以说是最有价值的东西之一，就是一种疯狂的职业道德，或者说我不应该用疯狂这个词。只是一种非常非常，我，我，我，
it's the knowledge that like I can work 40 hours a week or 50 hours a week. And then on top of that also study another 30 or 40 hours. And like, like back when I studied, I used to wake up at like 6am and I would track 15 minute intervals, like a consultant and like down to like showering, eating, exercise, like everything had a category in order to maximize like how much time I was studying. So anyways, you're not wrong. But there's a few thousand hours I could get back. Yeah.
这种感觉就是，我知道我每周可以工作40小时或50小时，在此之外还能再学个30或40小时。就像我以前学习的时候，我习惯早上6点左右起床，然后以15分钟为间隔进行记录，就像个顾问一样，连洗澡、吃饭、锻炼在内的每件事都有一个分类，以此来最大限度地增加学习时间。所以不管怎样，你没说错。但我确实能挤出好几千小时来。对啊。
If I wasn't doing that. All right. We got to wrap. I think we're past the hour mark on episode 61. I have no idea how I'm going to cut this up, and I haven't even gotten to the number one thing of 2021, which very quickly, and we're deferring 2022 outlook to another episode
如果我没在做那些事的话。好了，我们得结束了。我觉得第61期节目已经超过一个小时了。我完全不知道该怎么剪辑这期节目，而且我甚至还没聊到2021年的头号大事呢。简单提一下吧，2022年的展望我们要留到下一期节目再聊，
because we've run out of time, is my running. Running was definitely the highlight of the, what was probably, I'd say 2021 was the worst year of my running. Running was definitely the highlight of the what was probably, I'd say 2021 was the worst year of my life. Why was it the worst year of your life? I mean, you know.
因为我们的时间不够了，那件事就是我的跑步。跑步绝对是这一年里的亮点，不过2021年大概可以说是——我得这么说——2021年是我人生中最糟糕的一年。为什么这是你人生中最糟糕的一年？我的意思是，你懂的。
Okay, yeah. A lot of stuff happened. Plus too, 2021 was the first year in I don't know how many years that I haven't left the country. The last time, yeah, February 2020 was the last time I went to a different country. I was in New York.
好吧，是的。发生了好多事。另外，2021年也是我不知道多少年来第一次没有离开这个国家。上一次，对，2020年2月是我最后一次去别的国家。我在纽约。
I'm trying to get Strava to tell me how many miles or how many kilometers I biked last year. Have you biked more than I have run? That is the question. Well, so the problem is it has year to date, which is not applicable for last year. And it has all time. So I don't know whether I can actually get out the information that I would want. And I haven't really biked since like October because it got cold. But I started biking in like November, 2020, or I, I, I, I biked when I was at LSU and then like, I took like a two or three year when I moved to California, I like stopped
我正在尝试让Strava告诉我去年我骑行了多少英里或多少公里。你骑车的距离比我跑步的距离远吗？这就是问题所在。呃，问题是它只有年初至今的数据，这不适用于去年。而且它只有历史总数据。所以我不知道能不能真正拿到我想要的数据。而且我从10月份左右就没怎么骑车了，因为天冷了。不过我是从2020年11月左右开始骑车的，或者说，我以前在LSU上学时骑过车，然后后来，我花了大约两三年时间，等我搬到加州后，我就
biking for three or four years. Um, and then I started again in like late 2020. Um, uh, I think Ryan, if you're listening, you you're like you and i like went on a bike ride together like in like november 2020 and that was like what motivated me to get back into biking so you you get credit for that but um but since then uh strava says i've ridden uh 4156 kilometers um this is pretty good this is from when to when this is from uh november 2020 to now oh damn so it depends how much did you bike in november and december of 2020 i don't think it was like that much um i think it was maybe, hang on, we'll see if I can find that. The numbers are going to be super close.
停了三四年的骑车。然后，在2020年底左右我又重新开始骑了。呃，我想Ryan如果你在听的话，你——你和我一起去骑过车，大概是在2020年11月左右，那正是激励我重新开始骑车的动力，所以你得记上一功。不过，从那以后，Strava显示我已经骑了4156公里。这挺不错的，这是从什么时候到什么时候？这是从2020年11月到现在。哦，天哪。所以这取决于你在2020年11月和12月骑了多少。我觉得没骑那么多，我觉得大概是，等等，我们看看能不能找到那个数据。这两个数字会非常接近。
But this does not count because this does not count everything. Because when I spin indoors, that's not counted here, which is all that I've been doing recently. Okay, so you've definitely biked all that I've been doing recently. Okay. So you've definitely biked more than I was going to say. My 2021 stats are I ran 3,890 kilometers. Okay. That makes me feel bad, though, because I should have done a lot more.
但这并不算全面，因为这并没有计入所有数据。因为当我在室内骑动感单车时，这里是没有统计的，而这正是我最近一直在做的事情。好吧，所以你绝对骑了——我正要说呢。我2021年的统计数据是我跑了3890公里。好吧，这让我觉得有点糟糕，因为我本来应该做更多。多得多。
A lot more. You still beat me. You still beat me. Anyways, 2022, episode 62. How much are you running a day normally? It depends. I mean, I think my best month was 512 kilometers in August. So that works out to like 2018 or something, 17.
你还是赢了我。你还是赢了我。不管怎样，2022年，第62期。你平时一天跑多少？这得看情况。我的意思是，我觉得我最好的一个月是在8月跑了512公里。算下来大概是每天2018米左右，或者是17米。
I don't know, 13. I don't see all that. Oh, wait, wait. But do you run every single day uh basically in august basically i probably took off one or two days in august yeah okay so so i i do yoga with my mom uh or yoga do a 40 K once or twice a week. Um, but, but I, I haven't been biking since October, um, outside cause it's been cold and I definitely had some periods where I was not biking. Well, you know, towards the start of the year, I wasn't, I was
我不知道，13米。我没看全。哦，等等，等等。但你基本上每天都跑步吗？呃，基本上在8月，我大概只休息了一两天吧。对，好吧。所以我——我和我妈一起做瑜伽，或者做瑜伽，每周做一两次40公里的骑行。但是，但是，我从10月份开始就没在室外骑车了，因为天冷了，而且我确实有一段时间没骑车。好吧，你知道的，在年初的时候，我没有，我
biking like 18 kilometers. It was, I only started doing like 25 K a day and I only started doing 40 Ks like in the spring. So probably like, like probably next year, my, I will probably bike a lot more than, uh, than you. I'll have to figure out a way to get the data for how long for, for my, um, my biking, my, my, my spin, uh, bike, which I'm going to count towards my, my kilometers. Yeah. Well, we'll see if we can do a contest. We'll see who, uh, who,
骑了大约18公里。当时我每天才开始骑25公里左右，直到春天我才开始骑40公里。所以可能，可能明年，我，我骑车的距离可能会比你多得多。我得想个办法把我的骑行数据统计出来，包括我的室内动感单车，我要把它计入我的公里数里。好吧，我们看看能不能搞个比赛。看看谁，谁，
if you bike more than I run. I feel like I should probably, I feel like it probably should be, you know, like two times. If it's like about the same amount of exercise, I should probably be aiming to like twice the distance that you're running. Okay, we can do that. We can have a bet. How fast do you run normally?
如果你骑车的距离比我跑步的多。我觉得我可能应该，我觉得这大概应该是，你知道的，两倍左右。如果锻炼量差不多的话，我的目标应该是你跑步距离的两倍。好吧，我们可以这么做。我们可以打个赌。你平时跑步速度有多快？
It depends. So when I'm like yesterday, I went for – yesterday was – well, let's figure out. It was minus 8 but felt like minus 16. Minus 16 Celsius in Fahrenheit, which for all of you Americans was three degrees Fahrenheit. Oh my. So it was very cold. I thought it was cold here because there's snow on the ground and it is um it is 26 degrees
这得看情况。所以当我像昨天一样，我去了——昨天是——好吧，我们算算。气温是零下8度，但感觉像零下16度。零下16摄氏度，换算成华氏度，对于你们所有美国人来说就是华氏3度。哦天哪。所以非常冷。我以为这里很冷，因为地上有雪，而且是
which is cold so yeah it was very cold and i went for a 23k run and i ran at a um 4 45 so four minutes and 45 seconds per kilometer so if we change that to miles pace, it's like seven and a half minutes per mile, which is like that's like it's not fast, but it's also not slow. It's just like a decent pace. Yeah. Anyways, we'll wrap up 2021, 2022. It's going to be a better year for sure. Hopefully we'll have in-person conferences. Hopefully Bryce and I will be able to see each other in person at some point.
很冷，所以是的，非常冷，我去进行了一场23公里的跑步，我的配速是4分45秒，也就是每公里4分钟45秒。如果我们把它换算成英里配速，大约是每英里7分半钟，这就像是——它不算快，但也不算慢。这只是一个不错的配速。好吧，不管怎样，我们要总结2021年了，2022年肯定会是更好的一年。希望我们能有线下会议。希望布莱斯（Bryce）和我能在某个时候面对面见到彼此。
I'm certain that'll happen. Not so certain about in-person conferences. And I mean, C++23 is going to be finalized this year, which I think is going to be very exciting. And I think you and I both have some exciting... There's various different exciting work projects that we've got going on. We'll preview what we can preview in the next episode of 2022. And then also,
我确信这会发生。但对线下会议就没那么确定了。我的意思是，C++23将在今年最终敲定，我认为这会非常令人兴奋。而且我想你和我都有一些令人兴奋的……我们有很多各种各样令人兴奋的工作项目正在进行。我们会在2022年的下一期节目中预览我们能透露的内容。另外，
we got to have Dave Abrahams back on to finish up the rest of his story. And we got to have Sean Parent back on. Yeah. I think we got to expand our guest repertoire. Well, so that's actually my last thing was we mentioned CPP North. We talked about BQN.
我们得请戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯（Dave Abrahams）再来做客，讲完他故事的剩余部分。我们还必须请肖恩·帕朗（Sean Parent）回来。对。我觉得我们得扩大嘉宾阵容。好吧，所以这其实是我的最后一点，我们提到了CPP North。我们谈到了BQN。
And my last note is bringing on other PL people. So I think because we're on our quest to become number one in Slovenia. And in order to grow the podcast, I think what we need to do is start bringing someone. We technically already had Dave Abrahams from Swift. But let's bring on someone from Rust, someone from Go. We can even go to JavaScript and Scala and Ruby. We should bring on Andre, of course, someone from Go. We can even go to JavaScript and Scala and Ruby. We should bring on Andre, of course, at some point.
而我的最后一条笔记是引入其他编程语言（PL）领域的人。所以我想，因为我们的目标是成为斯洛文尼亚排名第一的播客。为了让播客发展壮大，我认为我们要做的是开始邀请某人。我们技术上已经邀请过来自Swift的戴夫·亚伯拉罕斯了。但让我们请一位来自Rust的、一位来自Go的人。我们甚至可以去找JavaScript、Scala和Ruby领域的人。当然，我们应该在某个时候请安德烈（Andrej）来，当然还有来自Go的人。我们甚至可以去找JavaScript、Scala和Ruby领域的人。当然，我们应该在某个时候请安德烈来。
Alexandrescu? Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's one of the creators of D. And he's just an amazing and charismatic storyteller. Oh, yeah. We'd have a good time with him. And we should also bring on Bartush. Maluski? Yeah.
亚历山德雷斯库（Alexandrescu）？对，对，对。他是D语言的创造者之一。他是一位惊艳且富有个人魅力的讲故事高手。哦，是的。和他在一起我们会度过一段美好时光。我们还应该请巴托什（Bartush）来。马卢斯基（Maluski）？对。
Oh, yeah. That'd be awesome. Why do we should also bring on Bartosz. Maluski? Yeah. Oh, yeah. That'd be awesome. Why do you want to bring on Bartosz? Same thing. Just like I think he has the same quality like Sean and Andre. He's going to have – he's a great storyteller. He's just a great storyteller. And then – well, wait.
哦，对，那太棒了。我们为什么——还应该请巴托什（Bartosz）·马卢斯基（Maluski）来？对。哦，对，那太棒了。你为什么想请巴托什来？同样的理由。就觉得他有着和肖恩以及安德烈相同的特质。他会——他是一个很棒的讲故事的人。他就是一个很棒的讲故事的人。然后——好吧，等等。
So there was like four of them that made up like the Northwest C++ user group. Who was the other horseman? So for those of you that don't know what the heck Bryce is talking about, in my better algorithm intuition talk that I first gave back in 2019 on that little European tour that we both went on, although admittedly yours was a lot longer than mine, I had talked to Eric Niebler about sort of his history. And he talked about this era where they were in the Pacific Northwest C++ user group in Seattle, or maybe it was just
所以有四个人构成了西北C++用户组。另一个“骑士”是谁？所以对于那些不知道布莱斯在说什么的人，在我2019年首次在欧洲巡回演讲的那场更好的算法直觉演讲中——虽然坦白说你去的比我长得多——我曾与埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）谈过他的一些历史。他谈到了他们在西雅图的太平洋西北C++用户组的那段时期，或者可能只是在
outside Seattle. And he, so himself, Eric, and then three other people would always, you know, after these C++ meetups, they'd go up and they'd go out and, you know, have a couple drinks and sometimes meet together on the weekends. And the four of them would always talk about, like, functional programming and all this awesome, you know, category theory stuff. And then they all sort of went in different directions. So those four people were Eric Niebler, Bartosz Maluski, who went and did category theory for programmers, and then Andrzej Alexandrescu. And the fourth one is Walter Bright, who is the main creator of the D language. And so basically, Walter and Andrzej went and did D. Eric went and did C++ ranges.
西雅图郊外。他和埃里克本人，再加上其他三个人，总是在这些C++聚会结束后，一起出去喝几杯，有时周末也会聚在一起。这四个人总是讨论函数式编程和所有这些棒极了的分类学之类的内容。然后他们各自朝不同的方向发展了。所以这四个人是埃里克·尼布勒、巴托什·马卢斯基（他去为程序员研究分类理论）、安德烈·亚历山德雷斯库。第四个人是沃尔特·布赖特（Walter Bright），他是D语言的主要创造者。所以基本上，沃尔特和安德烈去做了D语言。埃里克去做了C++的ranges（范围）。
And then Bartosz went and did category theory and functional programming. And yeah, we could potentially get them all on at the same time that might be a bit crazy that would be fun that would be fun and uh we gotta have patricia and uh chandler back at some point there's a lot well we obviously at some point we're gonna have titus on this podcast oh yeah yeah like i don't know that titus or the titus doesn't yet but at some point at some point we're gonna have yeah we also have to have Allison. We've got to do the thrust. We've got to have Allison on.
然后巴托什去做了分类理论和函数式编程。是的，我们有可能把他们四个人同时请来，虽然那可能有点疯狂，但会很有趣，那会很趣。而且呃，我们某个时候得请帕特里夏（Patricia）和钱德勒（Chandler）回来。有很多——当然我们在某个时候得请蒂图斯（Titus）上这个播客。哦，对，对，就像我不知道蒂图斯或者蒂图斯还不知道，但在某个时候，在某个时候我们会请——对，我们还得请艾莉森（Allison）。我们得做Thrust。我们得请艾莉森来。
Although I've since discovered that the thrust CUDA backend has an optimized partition path, and it's pretty clever. I haven't fully figured out how it works yet. And also I think I've determined that you need to have it done at least two. Well, no, you can't do it in one pass, but it's... Let's save it. Let's save it for the future episode where we have a dedicated time to talk about this. Anyways, lots of guests.
虽然我后来发现Thrust的CUDA后端有一个优化的分区路径，而且相当巧妙。我还没完全弄清楚它是怎么运作的。而且我想我也确定了你至少得做两次。好吧，不对，你不能一遍就完成，但它是……让我们留到以后吧。留到以后的节目中，我们会有专门的时间来聊这个。不管怎样，有很多嘉宾。
Yep. Happy New Year. Happy New Year to everybody. And we will preview 2022 next time. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没错。新年快乐。祝大家新年快乐。我们下次会预览2022年。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。